stéphane le foll le porte parole du
gouvernement et le ministre de
l'agriculture est l'invité de preuves
par 3 bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous donc pour ce rendez-vous de
public sénat avec l' agence
france-presse karine perez sera là dans
un instant et dailymotion et perrine
tarneaud bien sûr de public sénat
abordera tout à l'heure bah les dossiers
qui vous concernent directement les
dossiers agricoles avec bien sûr la
fronde contre les cours de la viande qui
est toujours aussi forte chez les
éleveurs qui vous attendent d'ailleurs
ce sera vendredi en bretagne mais avant
cela dit nous ces fameux folle si manuel
valls a l'intention de régler de sa
poche les 14000 euros correa écouter son
escapade son déplacement à berlin samedi
soir dans un falcon de la république
pour la finale de la ligue des champions
avec deux de ses enfants à bord c'est
une demande de l'opposition
écoutez moi je suis exprimé déjà sur ce
sujet manuel valls a été invité par
michel platini président de l'uefa à la
finale de ce qu'on appelle la ligue des
champions la france l'année prochaine
accueillera c'est un grand événement le
championnat d'europe tout le monde est
invité toute la vie qu'en tant que
premier ministre il prend les moyens qui
sont mises à la disposition du premier
ministre ils sont que de cet avion il ya
à chaque fois que le premier me se
déplace un certain nombre de personnels
nécessaires qui sont toujours là et il y
avait deux places il a donc emmené ses
deux enfants voilà la réalité des choses
a jusque là fait un peu la suspicion sur
la nature du déplacement quoi oui mais
vous êtes sur un événement d'accord avec
moi c'est pas ses fesses match à créteil
c'est le voilà c'est la finale de la
ligue des champions ne michel platini
président de l'uefa il ya une
affectation qui fait au premier ministre
de la france je crois que ce soit à
manuel valls s'il avait été pilonné pas
été prévu ministres ont pas ou peut-être
qu'il a des relations avec michel
platini je crois pas qu'il était invité
comme ça donc on est là aussi dans
j'allais dire un événement sportif avec
mention européenne
oui je sans doute au rand au delà des
rangs de l'opposition
oui parce que celui rangs de
l'opposition
finir sur ce sujet il ya d'autres choses
qui devraient être rappelés je comprends
histoire il y en a d'autres là je le
rappelle c'est un grand développement
fort sportif à l'échelle européenne et
le premier ministre de la france parce
qu'il éprouve vis de la france est
invitée voilà ils utilisent un avion
avec les moyens qui sont mis à sa
disposition
et puis j'irai pas moi faire d'autre
commentaire que cela et puis avait de
place dans cet avion toute façon c'est à
nous de fokine est mise à la disposition
du premier ministre bon mais on va finir
par découvrir qu'il n'y avait pas de
réunions de travail d'ailleurs à
l'elysée par était maintenant on parle
juste d'une rencontre de travail avec
michel platini alors ça j'en suis rien
ce que disent les conseillers d'eliseu
pas moi je dis que le sens de tout ça
c'est que c'est quand même la finale de
la ligue des champions bon voilà on est
invité et il est invité en tant que
premier ministre par michel platini
d'arguments que chacun apparemment
trouve un peu court
oui oui oui le convoi mais qu'est ce que
je peux comprendre je suis pas là pour
donner des soins qui compte mais je
rappelle simplement il ya la finale de
la ligue des champions on invite le
premier ministre de la france il doit
comme en voiture on perçoit on nous
considérait comme quoi il va avec les
moyens de la république il est probable
montée la france alors est ce que vous
comprenez je moi je vais mettre un mot
la maladresse stéphanois ne va pas se
transformer en faute politique bon c'est
la polémique ne retombe pas non je crois
pas parce que la polémique elle s'arrête
à partie au mans on regarde les choses
avec un tout petit peu comment dire est
de de recul il est invité par le
président de l'uefa la finale de la
ligue des champions en tant que premier
ministre je le rappelle n'est pas évité
la république exemplaire qui équipage
c'est le premier ministre de la france
voilà c'est la république de représente
aussi le gouvernement français pas
anodin bien c'est embarrassant non pas
du tout bas sinon j'ai tranquillement
tous les cas pas dans cette polémique
manuel valls dévoile 18 mesures devant
créer dit il des dizaines de milliers
d'emplois dans les petites et les
moyennes entreprises on va pas tous eu
toutes les citer mais il ya notamment le
renouvellement des cdd c'est important
de bonnes initiatives dit mendez maitien
sarnaks encore chez certains au ps
décidément c'est compliqué de faire des
mesures de droit certains frondeurs léon
les noms vous les connaissez mieux que
moi je crois oui mais j'ai compris que
j'ai vu d'ailleurs avec le discours de
l'heureux laurent baumel mais ça à la
fin du congrès dimanche qu' au-delà du
débat qui ait lieu qui a été tranché par
un vote au sein du parti socialiste et
pas les militants socialistes à plus de
60% pour la motion à
une adresse aux français qui a été
adoptée par 70 % des représentants des
militants puisqu'il y avait trois
motions qui l'ont adoptée il ya une
motion celle qui est conduite par les
frondeurs et par christian paul avec
laurent baumel qui avait décidé d'aider
dimanche d'ailleurs de considérer que
c'était pas comme ça qu'il fallait faire
donc je me dis simplement quand est-ce
qu'on peut trancher une ligne politique
cycle à chaque fois qu'il ya un débat
qui est tranchée par un vote c'est comme
s'il s'était rien passé c'est quand même
un sujet et il est posée aux frondeurs
bon après les mesures qui ont été
présentées elles sont avec un objectif
c'est-à-dire de d'enrichir lui dire
comme ça la croissance française en en
courant pour faire en sorte que avec
plus d'un pour cent de croissance on
puisse créer plus d'emplois et en
particulier la cible qui était la nôtre
qui a été présenté ce matin par manuel
valls est arbitré avant par le président
de la république c'est des petites et
les moyennes entreprises parce que c'est
de là qu'on a le potentiel de création
le plus important avec une première
mesure pour toutes ces toutes petites
entreprises celles qui n'ont aucun
salarié aujourd'hui c'est à dire plus
d'un million deux cent mille entreprises
le la citation avec une aide à faire en
sorte que ces petits entrepreneurs s'ils
en ont besoin puissent embaucher
franchissent le pas embauche donc en
levant certaines rigidités en levant
certaines rigidités en donnant surtout
de la lisibilité de la clarté je prends
une histoire posés par la question des
prud'hommes ça c'est très intéressé
très contesté patrick benquet quand
toujours et aujourd'hui on le sait
lorsqu'elle monte alors ça ne remet pas
on discute bien d'une chose précise les
indemnités de licenciement quelle
qu'elle soit dans un plan social autres
ça ce n'est pas concernée c'est
lorsqu'il ya un contentieux entre
l'employeur et le salarié qu'on va aux
prud'hommes pour traiter ce contentieux
aujourd'hui on est à 24 25 points de
moyenne et quelquefois on peut aller
jusqu'à 4 ans de débats avant d'avoir
une décision de rendu que ça soit pour
le l'employeur ou le salarié et dans ses
décisions rendues on a quelquefois sur
les mêmes sujets sémiologie de la
justice mais quand même sur les mêmes
sujets des différences qui peuvent aller
de 1 à 2 enfin sur les indignés sont
très majoritairement favorables aux
salariés en tous les cas l'édition qui
sont des leçons a alors que là il y aura
un barème y aura un barème donc
classé avant même nom parce qu'il donne
dans l'entreprise avec entre un plancher
et un plafond dans les quêtes bien sûr
la justice prud'homale fera et prendra
ses décisions mais que ça ça donne à
tout le monde un cadre ça donne à tout
le monde une visibilité ça permet
d'aller plus vite je pense aussi que à
salariés et je pense aux salariés en
particulier pas là dans le cadre des des
employeurs mais aux salariés ils ont
besoin aussi quant au bout de quatre ans
on a réglé le problème aux prud'hommes
que l'entreprise est là où disparu où
elle est toujours là mais il n'y a pas
de possibilité d'être réembauchés c'est
des sanctions qui sont prises tellement
longtemps après et tout ça perd aussi
alors même aller plus vite et encadrer
les sanctions ça permet de la visibilité
à tout le monde et parallèlement à ce
qu' il faudrait donc un plafond par
exemple pour les parachutes dorés des
grands patrons pendant l'âge à bille sur
les salaires et on l'a déjà dit je suis
désolée de dire les salaires ont été
plafonnés pour les grands patrons des
entreprises publiques l'accord mellal et
des parachutes dorés dans le privé on va
les parachutes dorés je me suis exprimé
suffisamment clairement sur le sujet
pour dire que moi quand je vois qu'ils
aient des parachutes dorés qui sont
versées alors qu'il ya devant nous
indigner mais après si si si ça suffise
à dire non seulement aux animer ce
qu'ils avaient bénéficié de tous a gelé
constaté dans les conseils des mets ça
sur les choses sont en train de changer
on accepte de moins en moins dans chez
les actionnaires privés des entreprises
que des chefs d'entreprise puissent
passer très peu de temps d'ailleurs la
tête d'une entreprise avoir pas
forcément beaucoup de résultats il
touchera chute de valeur journal s'étale
sur la réforme de la justice prud'homale
parce que la question de fond finalement
est de savoir si on va favoriser les
embauches en facilitant les
licenciements et ça les fondeurs encore
eux disent non c'est pas ça on n'a
jamais touché justement parce que la
question qui était posée sur les
licenciements ça aurait été de changer
le contrat à durée indéterminée ce que
proposait d'ailleurs monsieur de gattaz
c'est à dire de dire dès le contrat
signé il ya une clause qui dit si jamais
ça va mal je vous pose peut vous
licencier sans aucun bruit on a refusé
ça le problème c'est que on donne dans
le cadre du contentieux parce que ça ne
change rien sur les indemnités de
licenciement ni d'accord le cadre est ce
ça c'est pas évoqué le sujet c'est dans
le cadre d'un contentieux on essaie
d'encadrer des choses de telle manière
que et le salarié sages de ce
contentieux qu'est ce qui peut sortir et
l'employeur aussi pour éviter que
certains utilisent ce qui pourrait être
une procédure prud'homale comme un frein
à l'emploi car aujourd'hui les choses
sont plus claires pour les uns les
employeurs et surtout pour les salariés
je pense que ça fait aussi progresser il
faut qu'on crée dépannage et de sa vie
jamais vous avez exposé avec pédagogie
c'est très fort mais prud'hommes
stéphane le foll est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment de faire des gestes à sens
unique en direction du patronat
après le faible impact du allègements de
charges sur les embauches
des munitions qui est posée dans
l'économie française aujourd'hui c'est
que les créations d'emplois seront liés
aux entreprises la capacité qu'ont à
redresser l'économie à retrouver de la
croissance dans cette optique là les pme
les très petites entreprises sont une
cible spécifique que nous avons comment
dirais-je ciblé le dire parce que on
sait que c'est là pour notre potentiel
de création d'emplois le plus important
si on veut que dès qu'il ya de la
croissance les entreprises et ce réflexe
d'embauché au lieu d'attendre et de
reporter à plus tard pour des raisons x
ou y on se donne les outils et les
moyens de faire en sorte qu'ils
embauchent plus rapidement l'objectif
est toujours le même créez donc que vous
n'avez pas répondu à ma question sur les
gestes peut être à sens unique que parce
qu'on ne remet en aucun cas en cause des
droits des salariés la justice rendue
malte continuera à fonctionner le cadre
du contrat à durée indéterminée est
garantie dans sur la question du cdd qui
a été prolongée qui peut être plongé
deux fois mais dans le cadre des durées
légales du cdd on donne simplement la
possibilité aux salariés de rester dans
une entreprise 24 mois ce qui n'était
pas le cas aujourd'hui on cherche à
favoriser je le dis je les dis à
enrichir la capacité de création
d'emplois de la croissance française
d'accord mais pas l'impression de céder
au medef non le medef demandé autre
chose vous êtes vraiment des tacots
ronaldo remise en cause du contrat mais
voilà mais est ce que vous
voulez que le medef entende le message
sur une éventuelle réorientation du cse
c'est urgent a été question du réorienté
il existe 12 rappaz s'est pas de
responsabilité dans celle de ben ali
devraient être
en plus rediscuté en fonction de
l'évaluation qui sera faite cet été
l'objectif est de garder ce qui est ni
pour les entreprises mais en fonction de
ce qu on va constater de l'engagement du
patronat dans l'application la mise en
oeuvre du pacte de responsabilité
bon ben on fera les évaluations
nécessaires et peut-être les corrections
à correspond à ce que le gouvernement
évite dante est ce que ma mère est prêt
à utiliser à nouveau l'article 49-3 pour
faire passer à nouveau la loi macron
wind n'ont pour l'instant on essaiera de
travailler dans cette commission
spéciale à aller jusqu'au bout d'un
consensus qui permettent tout le monde
de voter cette loi voilà donc pour
l'instant on a eu un premier débat y est
un produit débats et même à creuser
jusqu'à 2 heures du matin ceux ci
reçoivent les débats reprennent à 17h
objectif aller jusqu'au bout dan lambda
débat solide sur le fond mais en même
temps en capacité d'aboutir à un journal
d'accord bien c'est toujours très sport
la question a dream la question des
migrants maintenant pour terminer cette
première partie de l'émission stéphane
le foll après la nouvelle évacuation
assez musclée à à paris est ce que vous
comprenez les mois le parti communiste
française s'est dit révolté est ce qu'en
fait la réalité ce n'est pas que le
gouvernement est totalement débordé par
les arrivées on est débordé on efface un
vrai problème mais personne ne le nie il
ya une arrivée très importante de
migrants mais est-ce qu'on peut accepter
dire à ceux qui ont manifesté et qui ont
beaucoup parlé ce qu'on peut accepter de
laisser des gens dans la rue à paris ou
ailleurs d'ailleurs dans des campements
de fortune dans des conditions à la fois
d'habitation et d'hygiène qui sont
déplorables et lamentable donc on doit
faire respecter un minimum cette règle
qui consiste à dire si on doit rester en
france on le fait dans des conditions
acceptables et digne donc à partir de là
on coupa on ne peut pas laisser des
campements comme ça a été le cas où
comme c'est souhaité parce que
l'alternance en hébergement durable et
messi alors c'est quand on l'a vu on
était
oui mais ça a été refusé il ya eu à
nouveau un déplacement on héberge en
même temps on analyser dossiers ceux qui
ont une revendication de droit d'asile
et qui correspondent aux critères
peuvent rester en france les autres on
ne peut pas tout accueillir tout le
monde d autres doivent pouvoir retourner
chez eux et on doit le faire avec le
souci de la dignité des êtres humains
sans avoir de parole ni blessantes ni
d'actions qui pourraient considérer qu
ici on traiterait des gens est justement
manière au domaine là encore il ya une
partie de la gauche qui vous renvoie ce
que faisait la droite à l'église saint
bernard en 1996 c'est pas vrai c'est pas
pareil par les églises saint bernard je
m'en souviens c'était le 18e c'était bon
une église il y avait là un sujet on est
confronté que j'aimerais
non oui mais hier aujourd'hui on est
confronté à cette
responsabilité peut pas laisser les
choses comme ça c'est pas vrai les mêmes
qui aujourd'hui peuvent se mobiliser
bien le dire mais qu'est ce qui se passe
comment on peut accepter de laisser des
gens dans la rue des campements qui
pourrait d'ailleurs s'étendre qu'est-ce
qui se passerait à s'opposer à la
question qu'est ce que fait le
gouvernement le gouvernement il agit
avec une une logique humaine une logique
claire d'application des réseaux torrent
est bien sûr très bien en faux sinon ça
ne peut pas entendu allez on va
emprunter maintenant si vous le voulez
bien le chemin qui mène à 2017 j'ai déjà
engagés comme françois hollande
qui s'est engagé dans ce qui ressemble
actuellement une pré-campagne ce
week-end on peut dire que le congrès ps
à poitiers a marqué une borne avant les
questions de karine perrelle oncle
agence france presse un chemin un chemin
semé d'embûches avec quentin calme mais
soyons fiers aussi du président de la
république qui incarne avec courage la
voix de la france ce fut l'une des
images les plus marquantes du congrès
socialiste
une salle qui se lèvent spontanément
pour acclamer françois hollande je suis
persuadé que françois est en train de
vous entendre
et ses applaudissements sont importants
parce qu'il est un grand président de la
république et parce que le pays doit le
savoir
un premier ministre plus loyal que
jamais l'idée même d'une primaire à
gauche pour 2017 s'efface avec la photo
de famille du congrès rassembler le
parti derrière françois hollande
première étape alors que les chances de
réussite semblent maigres françois
hollande le présent la république c'est
notre leader charismatique soit leader
emblématique qui traverse une passe
difficile mais dans ce qui s'est passé
au congrès de poitiers c'est la
démonstration qui s'est faite comme cela
instantanée que tout le monde est
derrière françois hollande et c'est
comme cela que nous en sortirons l'image
du chef de l'état ne s'améliore pas dans
l'opinion interview pour parler aux
jeunes grande cérémonie du panthéon rien
n'y fait depuis des mois françois
hollande est au plus bas dans les
sondages
je n'ai jamais vu françois hollande même
temps premiers secrétaires et encore
moindre président république agir en
fonction des sondages ça n'a jamais été
sous sa façon de fonctionner ça l'est
encore moins aujourd'hui et plus que
jamais je crois qu'il ya une stabilité
un cap qui s'est fixé une sérénité
d'ailleurs je crois que les gens qui le
voit au quotidien sont peut-être surpris
d'ailleurs de sa sérénité parce que je
crois qu'il est en confiance sur ce
qu'il fait il y avait un plan travail
sur les cinq ans à venir trois premières
années sont passées les résultats sont
peut être un peu en retard mais la
réalité c'est pour lui il ya une feuille
de route et il attend ces résultats-là
cette semaine le chef de l'état entend
jouer une autre partition et multiplier
les déplacements en régions ainsi ils
occupent l'espace médiatique et se
montre proche des gens mais l'opinion
n'attend qu'une seule chose la baisse du
chômage
depuis 2012 la france compte 640 mille
demandeurs d'emploi en plus voilà karine
père est avec nous notre cancers de la
peau ou encore karine vos questions sur
le parti socialiste et françois hollande
oui donc une popularité en baisse un
chômage surtout qu'ils ne baissent pas
les signes de reprise économique très
faible il reste moins de deux ans avant
la prochaine élection présidentielle
comment est-ce que françois hollande va
faire si vous êtes réélu à la la la la
et qu'est-ce que vous rajouter avec des
orages la sécheresse la montée des eaux
le climat
ont su à pleurer je suis tout le monde
donc il faut rester en politique je
comprends la question gelé parfaitement
enregistré on va me la poser dix fois
vingt fois il faut que vous sachiez
quand même que moi quand il y avait un
françois hollande à 3% les sondages
j'avais la même question il vous fait
vous êtes un peu à côté de la plaque
monsieur le foll vous soutenez volant
vous avez niveau de ces sondages qu'est
ce que c'est que cette histoire bon à
l'époque je répondais mais non moi j'ai
une conviction se trouve qui s'est passé
ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui c'est pas
la même situation je sais parfaitement
que la situation est difficile je sais
et je connais les sondages je sais pas
s'ils ont baissé parce que j'ai vu que
certains remontent et doté non mais
ça
sa candidature alors ça c'est une autre
question
ça c'est une autre a terminé sur la
première la célébration dans laquelle on
est très bien dans parfaitement compris
que c'était pas facile mais en même
temps le problème n'est pas uniquement
de se dire comment faire pour être
candidat ou être élu en 2007 de toute
façon de toute façon ça passera par le
le fait que la france se sera redressée
et que les français leur ont perçu comme
tel donc là aujourd'hui mois hommes
politiques avec les difficultés qu'on
pourra évoquer aussi dans le domaine
agricole quelle est la responsabilité
qui
dirait je pèse sur mes épaules comme aux
présentes à 2 x et de faire réussir la
france après je suis sûr si nous y
arrivons et on commence à y arriver
malgré tout est bien mais tu es un gros
1,6 bien sûr si on échoue et je peux le
dire ce sera extrêmement difficile c'est
ce qu'il a dit d'ailleurs très justement
s'il n'y a rien qui change de chômage je
ne serai pas candidat
d'ici là il avait annonc é u il avait
annoncé donc deux périodes dans le
quinquennat une période de mesure
difficile une période de redistribution
est-ce que les français peuvent
s'attendre à autre chose que la baisse
de d'impôt qui est prévue à la rentrée
baptisé suffisamment entendu parler de
la hausse d'impôts pour que la baisse
c'est ça vous passez à les 4 milliards
pour les français remportent mois pour
parce que je n'en mets c'est une
plaisanterie le mois de septembre est un
mois très important la baisse des impôts
et la suppression de la première tranche
c'est une partie la redistribution mais
vous n'allez pas passer ça disant est ce
qu'il y aura déjà d'autres à chaque fois
avec les journalistes c'est très simple
il faut quelque chose qui ait décidé on
passe à la suivante hop hop moi je veux
que traversent certains
parfaitement conscience et il faudra
compter là dessus une expression
extrêmement forte donc la baisse des
impôts c'est au mois de septembre ça
vous allez le marché n'avait pas de
moyens et les classes moyennes première
tranche et classes populaires et classes
moyennes ça touchera
9 millions de ménages sont touchés donc
la redistribution je vais pas dire
qu'elle se résume pour cette année à la
baisse des impôts med c'est donc ça le
point fort vous à la hauteur de la
hausse pour que vous soyez des
commentateurs et les de la baisse
message du porte parole
silence on tremble je vois le parti
socialiste a prévu de trancher cette
question qui revient la question des
primaires en automne à l'automne 2016
seulement on sait bien qu'à l'automne
2016 il sera plus temps d'organiser à
une primaire donc ça veut dire que voilà
je dis je vais me répéter donc ça va
être très désagréable pour ceux qui
l'ont déjà entendu j'ai déjà dit si le
volant de la république et les candidats
je vois pas comment on fait dix ans de
prison deux républiques delizée pour
venir faire des primaires repartir le
soir après les débats revenir et puis se
poser la question de savoir si il est
désigné ou pas et puis de dire s'il
n'était pas désigné qu'est-ce qui fait
il reste président ne restent pas tout
ça n'a pas de sens c'est pas la peine
d'ergoter sur cette question des
primaires
oui mais décidant les papilles du ps
quand on est en phase de conquête jeudi
institutionnellement un président de la
république s'ils se présentent aussi se
reposant on va dire alors tu peux on
refait des primaires mais ça voudrait
dire que tout ce qui a été fait ne
compte pas c'est ça que ça voudrait dire
mais qui peut penser qu'à partir de là
on peut s'engager pour gagner personne
de logica et du raisonnable soit là ça
ira donc ne nous moi je propose ne pas
poser ses questions et attendent de
savoir si françois hollande sera
candidat ça ne sert à rien s'il est
candidat je vois pas comment on organise
des primaires c'est simple poser les
questions non
vous avez lancé une invitation aux
commentateurs pour cette année qu'il
martèle bien que la redistribution qui
je leur ferai d'ailleurs la bd unique
aux commentateurs qui disent que bah en
fait on est déjà entrée dans l'après
hollande
où je le sens
certains d'entre vous rue oui oui ça mc
ou cdd des malveillants ou ce sont des
gens qui peuvent se tromper
1,30 arriver si je faisais la liste de
tout ce que j'ai entendu
qu'elle était contredit alors que
j'avais déjà en face de moi qui me
disait que c'était sûr que ça allait se
passer comme ça je pense y en a un
certain nombre qui est fier d'être est
de repasser l'année 2010 1 et s'il le
souhaitait ce contrat sont possibles
bourges et vu comment il a présenté sa
tribune j'ai bien vu que ça déjà arrivés
juste à la fin du congrès c'est possible
mais alors franchement la tribune que
j'ai lu au-delà du fait qu'elle ait
signé matthieu pigasse qui est lui-même
un banquier qui a sûrement beaucoup de
qualités mais la faiblesse des
propositions et de l'analyse franchement
il confondante dire c'est de la faute de
l'europe et de l'allemagne si on est
dans une politique d'austérité bon
ensuite dire mais pour sortir de cette
politique il faut qu' une baisse
d'impôts général avec une coalition
européenne bon et oublié de dire c'est
pour ça que je le répète et je le dis
très fort que la baisse des impôts elle
s'engage cette année donc si c'est la
question de la baisse des impôts pour la
relance elle s'engage cette année donc
arnaud montebourg il faut qu'ils
relisent de ce qui va être fait c'est
pour ça qu'il faut faire beaucoup il
veut dire la baisse des impôts elle est
engagée donc vous voyez bien que c'est
faible je comprends pas une façon
peut-être de prendre date pour lui oui
mais voilà si prend date avec des
arguments comme ça
politiquement le dur de remonter la
pente il avait fait des choses quand il
était au gouvernement sur le made in
france sur cette volonté qu'ils avaient
de développer une politique industrielle
de soutenir des entreprises et moi
j'étais avec lui sur ces sujets là
extrêmement
dense en phase complètement j'ai mis en
place vient de france lors de france et
je continue ce que je pense qui est une
bonne stratégie d'identifier la
production française mais là je trouvais
que c'était voilà pas la hauteur
d'evreux doter un cavalier seul de sa
part dans les mois qui viennent pour
2010 m je le redoute pas jugeant peut
l'imaginer la preuve c'est que ces deux
tribunes elle est arrivée il n'était pas
apprécié on l'appelait on pouvait
l'imaginer en fait on veut bien sûr mais
moi je sais pas moi qui déciderai sélune
accord elle attendra dans les logiciels
de calcul de l'elysée pas du tout je
sais même pas si ciel de calcul c'est
tout à fait possible vous posez la
question je vous répond c'est possible
c'est lui qui décidera pas moi qui vais
décider à sa place mais vu ce que j'ai
vu dimanche je me dis oui il a peut-être
ça en tête mais après alors là vous
dites que vous criez quoi
l'irresponsabilité au jeu rien du tout
me dis que je les dis tout de suite que
si il veut être candidat et qu'il part
avec les bases qui était celle du jeu du
journal du dimanche on n'ira pas bien
loin pour gagner une élection s'il faut
le rassemblement avec les autres partis
de gauche comment concrètement ça va se
faire avec les a jugées non mais est ce
que l'idée c'est de faire revenir cécile
duflot gouvernement après les régionales
voilà c'est assez simple comme sujet il
faut faire un rassemblement donc oui si
oui d'abord est ce qu'elle veut si si du
show je crois pas là qui est évidemment
j'ai pas l'impression que la vie de
revenir première chose pour essayer de
faire ça c'est que le vainqueur françois
hollande la merci des récents contacts
avec l faut plutôt trop récents contacts
avec elle tout simplement partir de
postulats simple parce qu'il veut
rentrer ou pas deuxième point majeur
c'est pas le sujet de qui rentre au
gouvernement c'est celui de savoir si il
ya une dynamique politique qui implique
l'ensemble des points pour engager des
partis qui sont liées à la gauche et aux
écologistes
si c'est pour faire entrer des champs
gouvernement et ne pas avoir derrière
l'engagement d'un soutien d'europe
écologie les verts ça ne servira à rien
donc il faut rester là aussi cohérent on
doit avoir une stratégie de
rassemblement il faut qu on la construit
à 500 pour la radio nationale europe
ecologie
mais aujourd'hui ils ne sont pas le
parti tout seul dans beaucoup de régions
alors il ya des risques pour nationale
c'est vrai donc
l'appel du parti socialiste et de
favoriser de rassemblement en
particulier quand il ya un plan national
avec oman mais ça se travaille ça se
discute il va y avoir sur la tisserie
écologique quand même un grand sujet
avec l'aco 21 un grand sujet moi j'ai vu
j'ai discuté hier avec pascal canfin qui
est un ancien ministre
écologiste du gouvernement sur les
grands enjeux sûr on y reviendra
peut-être le stockage du carbone et sur
la capacité qu'on a avec les terres
agricoles
régénérescence des terres agricoles à
stocker aussi la matière organique et
donc à stocker du carbone donc on va
discuter de ça donc on a un enjeu majeur
et jeffrey avait que lui avec d'autres
un cap 21 c'est un moment de politique
écologique c'est un choix stratégique
pour la france
bien sûr mais pour l'europe et pour la
planète donc c'est quand même à leur jeu
qui vaut le coup et ça il faut qu'on
s'engage pleinement totalement il ya des
écologistes avec lequel on travaille je
voulais dire parce qu'elle complet est
ici à la photo on a entendu ce week end
à poitiers le premier ministre parlait
nicolas sarkozy comme un problème pour
la france jean christophe cambadélis l'a
comparé à un enfant de 3 ans est ce que
vous pensez que françois hollande doit
partir dans un espèce de pré campagne
électorale et lui répondre aussi bon je
pense que ces réponses faisait suite et
aux attaques qui avaient été portées le
samedi d'avant
je pense que en débat politique de
nicolas sarkozy a parlé d'un président
d'une terrifiante médiocrité oui et puis
qu'il ne peut qu'il ne nomme pas en
disant moi je veux un bon donc je veux
dire là dessus ça doit rappeler à tout
le monde dans un débat public et
politique
il ya aussi devant les français à porter
d'abord des avis et des contradictions
sur des questions de fond voilà c'était
un peu ras des pâquerettes de chaque
côté mais je suis le premier qui a été
plus que ras des pâquerettes c'est à
dire même en dessous des pâquerettes
c'était nicolas sarkozy donc il faut
qu'on est en tête le fait que avec
nicolas sarkozy et les ex ump s'est tout
d'un débat de fond sur une conception de
la république ça c'est sûr sur une
conception économique et social ça c'est
sûr aussi il ya un débat majeur et sur
la manière dont on prépare l'avenir la
question d'éducation étant au coeur de
la préparation de l'avenir ça c'est une
différence essentielle donc vous ne
remettez du fonds le produit c'est que
les gens pas simplement à hurler parce
que ils étaient ils étaient pour gorée
et qu'il avait fait une cuite j'ai bien
compris que ça mais je dis sa tribune
c'est quoi c'est pas à la hauteur des
enjeux mais pas du tout mais sur le fond
la carte au ghana oui justement sur la
question du fond comment vous faites
avec un parti socialiste qui a perdu à
peu près la moitié de ses militants en
trois ans qui se voit reprocher le fait
de cette coupe et des intellectuels qui
n'a pas produit une idée depuis trois
ans comment vous allez faire justement
ce qu'il faut une machine de guerre pour
pouvoir gagner simple il faut pas parler
des machines de guerre il faut deux
machines organiser une machine qui
produit de machines qui
crée de la dynamique qui créent de leur
vie parce qu'on avait mais là encore on
n'avait plus joué mais c'est jamais
facile d'être un parti au gouvernement
on souvient le quand lionel jospin était
au gouvernement on était à tête du parti
socialiste on a passé la barre jeudi
d'ailleurs des cent mille votants au
monde dijon en 2003 avant c'était bien
en dessous donc on est monté beaucoup
plus haut avec 180 mille ou cent
soixante dix mille votants au moment du
de la primaire de 2006 qu'après on est
en tournée autour de 110 mille cent
quinze mille votants bon on débat c'est
70 mille votants pour cambadélis la wii
sur un peu plus de 110 mille adhérents
sont venus l'adhérence et des étiages du
parti saucisses qu'on a connue mais il
faut redresser cette pente on est
capable aujourd'hui on est aux
responsabilités bon les gens pas forcé
son talent qu il n'y a pas eu viol n'a
envie de conquête les gars espèce de
regard qui est porté sur ce qu'on fait
donc c'est moins facile mais on va
arriver dans une phase au parti
socialiste jean christophe cambadélis
pour aussi animer ce débat politique et
les ensembles de faire des propositions
et travailler on les attend merci karine
vous inquiétez pas dernier volet des
vraies stars 3d mais maintenant on va
aborder les dossiers agricoles avec
perrine tarneaud toujours bien sûr je le
disais tout à l'heure la crise dans
l'élevage et vous êtes attendus à
nouveau en bretagne ça risque d'être
sportif pour vous un nouveau vendredi
mais voyons d'abord si le secteur
agricole vous l'avez dit réputé
pollueurs peut aussi montrer un autre
visage voir apporter des solutions aux
dérèglements climatiques reportage de
jérôme rabier
depuis 2001 et la reprise de la ferme
familiale cyrille milard est à la tête
d'une exploitation comme il en existe
des centaines en seine-et-marne donc ici
vous êtes au coeur de la bri centre de
la seine-et-marne je souhaite à peu près
de 140 hectares
la wii a du maïs j'ai du blé derrière
moi mais je suis aussi du chambre alors
le champ c'est une culture que j'ai
rajouté pour essayer de réduire ma
dépendance aux produits phytosanitaires
puisque ça utilise zéro phytosanitaire
en 2007 il franchit le pas et passent un
contrat mae pour mesures agro
environnementales qui l'amène arrêts
rires de 50 % l'utilisation de produits
phytosanitaires
un véritable défi pour lequel il a fallu
investir notamment dans les technologies
en fait
je suis dans la parcelle l'attend
maîtrise davantage les techniques de
pulvérisation donc on arrive à faire de
la réduction et puis on essaye de deux
mètres l'ado la bonne dose au
bon moment c'est à dire au moment où la
plante à une absorption maximum mais
cela passe aussi par des bonnes
pratiques comme le binage mécanique qui
permet de désherber sans utiliser de
produits chimiques mais la diminution
drastique peut aussi avoir des effets
indésirables
c'est ça c'est l'ergot voilà le bleu
grains noirs là c'est à dire c'est très
dangereux pour la santé humaine est on
est on est tenus de ne pas en avoir dans
des lots de blé donc la dernière récolte
j'ai un g1 l'eau qui est contaminée
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas comment je
vais pouvoir le commercialiser persane
en eux cyrille milard a préféré ne pas
reconduire le contrat de réduction de 50
% de produits phytosanitaires même s'il
conserve une partie des pratiques
utilisées un subtil équilibre à trouver
faire des efforts ok mais à un moment
donné il faut ménager la chèvre et chou
j'irai pour
pour faire de la réduction sans mettre
en péril notre entreprise et donc pour
ça que je suis un peu revenu en arrière
parce que j'étais arrivé un peu au trot
ou des choses et aujourd'hui oui on peut
dire j'ai atteint un équilibre comparé à
2001 il utilise 25 à 30 % de produits
phytosanitaires en moins mais il le sait
il faudra faire davantage dans le cadre
du nouveau plan ecophyto du gouvernement
c'est moins 50% d'ici 2025 il faudra
atteindre au risque de mettre en péril
un modèle économique agricole déjà
fragile
aux questions au ministre de
l'agriculture
avec cet exploitant un peu un peu modèle
me le dit lui-même ça va être difficile
pour lui il est heureux de revenir en
arrière c'est difficile de faire plus
sans mettre en péril son exploitation
tout d'abord c'est un exploitant qui
cherchent et qui cherche à améliorer sa
performance
économique en même temps qu'il a fait
des choix en terme écologique en
particulier avec cette tête d'assolement
quelle chambre malick sarr exploitant le
modèle oui mais je pourrais vous emmener
dans des exploitations qui ont qu'ils
sont cons basculer dans ce qu'on appelle
l'agroécologie avec des couvertures de
sol et aide à seulement comme ça avec
des techniques aujourd'hui leur
permettent d'avoir la qualité et la
quantité avec des systèmes extrêmement
beaucoup plus économes dans quelle est
la question qui est posée c'est ce qui
était dit qui est très juste c'est un
changement de mentalité qui est pas
toujours oui c'est pas évident secteur
d'activité qui souffrent oui c'est pas
évident c'est pas évident de faire
passer ce message parce que
techniquement ça nécessite des
évolutions et qui est un équilibre ça a
été très bien dit la chèvre et le chou
entre la dimension économique de
l'exploitation agricole et sa prise en
compte écologique donc c'est ça qu'on
aime et les céréaliers peuvent peut-être
le faire parce que l'on est plus de
moyens financiers aussi les sirènes ils
peuvent fermée sur une rotation culture
c'est un enjeu très important pour
l'équilibré écologique et en même temps
économiques mais d'autres font de la
polyculture élevage étant un système
aussi qui est extrêmement performant
dans la capacité qu'il a fertilisé des
sols par l'élevage et en même temps à
permettre une production de céréales et
protéines végétales donc on est sur un
moment c'est ça que j'essaie d'expliquer
à ceux qui disent ça va jamais assez
vite tiens je rejoins d'ailleurs de le
débat sochaux va c'est vrai que c'est un
pas assez vite on le dit souvent le
grenelle de l'environnement avait prévu
- 50% en 2018 sauf qu'ils avaient décidé
de baisser de -50% sans se poser la
question des méthodes des techniques de
ce qu'on a fait nous c'est qu'on a
changé les bêtes on a fait des
propositions de méthodes et techniques
et qu'on accompagne s'est mise en oeuvre
de méthodes et techniques parce qu'on
sait quelle sera leur objectif avons
maintenant ça a été dit son plateau ça a
été dit aussi sur les questions de
rotation de cultures une couverture de
sol ça va être l'objet aussi du débat
sur la pomme 21 avec celle là l'objectif
du du cap 4 gramme pour 1000 g stocké
dans les sols parce que la matière
organique des sols du carbone qui est
fixé par l'air et bien une fois que vous
la stocker dans les soldes c'est du
stockage de carbone et ça c'est très
important à la fois pour régénérer les
sols les rendent beaucoup plus productif
et bien sûr avoir beaucoup moins de
mission de gaza les fait comment parler
des films tôt sanitaires et une
association de consommateurs qui vous
demandent d'interdire la
commercialisation du glyphosate
c'est notamment le principal ingrédient
du rwanda les jardiniers amateurs
connaissent au motif que ces produits
sont cancérigènes vous y réfléchissez le
glyphosate est un herbicide dire que
quand vous ne devinez pas là vous avez
pas d alternative a pour seul
but d'assurer donc toutes les
précautions qui doivent prises sont
impératives il ya maintenant pour les
agriculteurs ce qu'on appelle des
certificats de phyto d'utilisation de
phytosanitaires pour que tout le monde
fasse très attention contrairement aux
sports en interne on l'interdît n'en
restons si je l'interdisait mais j'ai
pas d'alternative qu'est ce qui se passe
qu'est ce qui vous dit votre
agriculteurs et aux déballages et de
lire partout et j'ai pu de production et
donc on viendra me dire mais vous êtes
en train de détruire la production
agricole
en même temps je sais que mon on peut
s'en passer ça j'ai des éléments pas moi
des agriculteurs c'est ce qu'on essaye
de diffuser aux jardiniers du dimanche
jardinières mama lui il a
la main lourde j'en vois qui
sulfate tous les week-ends je redis
arrêté c'est pas un peu d'herbe ça n'a
pas jamais fait de mal à personne alors
il faut arrêter galette on utilise
beaucoup trop et là dessus il ya un
engagement qui a été pris juste auront
peut-être un peu d'informations à faire
et de l'information et le glyphosate est
effectivement une en danger un poison
oui c'est quelque chose dont je
n'aimerais pas s'en passer c'est
aujourd'hui sur les systèmes des petits
existe on utilise lequel vous êtes
d'ailleurs jeudi au passage une partie
des ogm simon ça que j'ai toujours été
content tout ces ogm de monsanto une
partie du maïs monsanto est fait pour
résister aux diffuseurs en quelque sorte
douce mais du maïs vous mettez du
diffuseur il vous reste que le maïs bon
et ça c'est facile sauf qu'on s'aperçoit
avec ces ogm depuis 15 16 ans et j'ai
des premiers éléments de retour des
américains des américains depuis ce
qu'ils utilisent des ogm et du
glyphosate plein pot aujourd'hui le
glyphosate connaît des résistances hier
les des plantes qui résiste au niveau aa
et donc ils sont obligés de revenir à
les organochlorés ce qui est encore pire
c est ce qu on avait abandonné il ya
vingt ans pour parce qu'on n'arrive plus
à lutter contre une certaine de la
résistance de certaines plantes on est
obligé de monter j'allais dire en
langage en armement en gare moi je dis
stop on a eu notre stratégie à mettre en
place l'accord l'art maintenant on va
parler d'une à défaut et des
agriculteurs je peux pas le faire en
leur disant allez hop vous arrêter tout
ça et puis voilà c'est comme ça c'est
pas sûr tous ceux qui sont de bonne
volonté comme sélectionnés et ce jeune
excellent c'est cette volonté ses
membres allaient
être un peu le redis c'est celle de la
fédération nationale porcine qui
souffrent
d'une baisse des cours de viande vos
précédentes rencontres ont été houleuses
vous y allez avec quoi vendredi dans
votre panier le jv avec la volonté de
s'y trouver des solutions je les dis
quand j'avais été alors oui je vais
apporter des soins c'est toujours pareil
vous pensez que s'il suffisait que
j'amène des solutions un miracle les
prix augmentent la production porcine se
développe non c'est quand même plus
compliqué que ça donc juste que je veux
dire c'est pas que je me défends vous
êtes impuissant je remercie non je suis
pas un puissant je vais trouver des
solutions je vais agir et j'agis j'agis
tous les jours j'ai eu des réunions
aujourd'hui sur les questions de mise en
mouvement de l'ensemble de la filière de
la responsabilité de la grande
distribution des choses qui ont bougé
hier il ya un grand distributeur qui a à
proposer bon on est en train d'essayer
de faire bouger les choses bouger les
choses pour quoi vous faire en sorte que
dans cette filière le
l'écart qui existe aujourd'hui entre ce
qui est le prix à la production payer en
particulier avec un système qu'on
appelle le cadran aujourd'hui et ce qui
est la réalité de ce que peut payer le
consommateur il ya un écart au jury
qu'il faut qu'on réduise il faut qu'on
s'organise différemment trop longtemps
et ça vaut pour la viande bovine aussi
on a eu des processus ou produisent et
on produisait on allait sur le cadran et
ont souhaité mais vous vous pouvez jouer
les pubs et moi je ne peux pas je ne
suis pas autorisé à je mobilise je
mobilise des acteurs pour le faire et en
même temps par contre je suis autorisé
par la loi là je vais le faire à faire
des choix qui vont venir aussi rappeler
à tout le monde que les promotions dans
la viande ça peut pas être tout le temps
c'est pas tout le temps les soldes voilà
mais visiblement c'est le problème du
parcequ'il est justement prendre
position et ça d'accord je peux le faire
et je le dis d'ailleurs ce cet après
midi oui si le vendredi 6 d'ici là il
n'y a pas d'accord interprofessionnel
sera la première fois qu'un ministre va
utiliser et eu un arrêté il va fixer
comme ça des durées de manière aussi
claire dans le domaine de l'agriculture
de l'agroalimentaire je crois que ça n'a
jamais été fait et de jus de fruit et
notre profession qui respecte à d'être
un peu en colère c'est aussi vendredi
vinexpo le grand salon mondial du vin
bordeaux dimanche pardon c'est tout le
week-end enfin ça commence à la fin à la
fin de la semaine
est-ce que le gouvernement va bien
déposé un amendement pour revenir sur la
disposition qui a été voté par le sénat
pour assouplir la loi evin amendements
auquel l'ensemble de la profession de la
filière vin et bien sûr favorable oui
moi j'avais eu un débat j'ai eu avec
marisol un choix qu'on a fait ensemble
je connais les problèmes de la santé je
connais la comédie avec la pression qui
existe aussi pour ceux qui disent le vin
et les alcools c'est dangereux et en
même temps je sais ce que c'est que le
vin dans notre culture et votre boulot
c'est de défendre avant syrte et je
devais je défends du levain alors là ce
qui vient vous dire que j'ai pas défendu
le vin je les attends à la fois sur la
remise en place
tout à fait comme les autres mais
justement garde monsieur césar si les
fonds le 20 juin
césar qui a fait un moment ils auraient
pu réfléchir parce qu'en fait c'est tous
des alcools qui l'a mis donc je vois pas
quel est l'intérêt qu'on a aujourd'hui à
donner des sentiments est trop large
bélie trop large et puis ça que vous
soyez
je suis j'ai discuté avec marisol
touraine à un moment où sur la loi santé
j'avais des députés qui voulaient aller
remettre et durcir encore la loi evin
pour dire on ne touche à rien à rien et
elle a été d'accord et elle a tenu
pendant la loi santé un discours qui a
été extrêmement bas qu'avec un plus pas
moins
peut-être une dernière question celle où
le loup
est ce que peut faire le mieux de
ministres courir après voilà donc il y
avait il ya autant de d'abattage
éventuel possible à 36 en 2015-2016
qu'il y en a eu l'année dernière vous
confirmez vous restez sur le même ton
reçoit sur le même avec l'objectif était
le werder une hausse des prélèvements
possibles je comprends déjà on a
augmenté on n'a jamais était aussi loi
dans la capacité qu'on a donnée aux
éleveurs de se protéger de tir et
d'avoir des tirs de dissuasion et de le
niveau du prélèvement quand je suis
arrivé je crois qu'on dit à 8,6 est loin
aujourd'hui à 30 avec ses 36 on a
prélevé que 24 d'ailleurs pas abattu bah
tu ne connais même pas arrivé et là on a
un problème là aussi d'or isation en
même temps la pression je le dis ceux
qui sont sensibles à ces questions là
j'entends souvent mais oui mais pourquoi
il ya d'autres pays où il ya des lions
il ya des tic oui mais là la pression
qui s'exerce sur l'élevage elle est
continue elle est extrêmement lourde il
ya eu ce c'est le seigneur vainement où
je sais et je les ai vus erreurs des
erreurs et toi rumeurs font peur qu'ils
ont peur leur physiquement pour eux donc
il faut qu'on soit capable d'apporter
des réponses et ses réponses c'est en
vous et en même temps on essaie de
discuter aussi sur les évolutions
nécessaires de la directive habitats
haut niveau à travers tous les cas le
nombre de prélèvements ne changera pas
merci beaucoup stéphane le foll merci
père et nous devons soirée tous à la
semaine prochaine notre invité sera jean
pierre raffarin